Because a Service Worker runs in
the background, they have a different
life cycle, which is completely
separate from your Web page.
And In order to use a Service Worker,
it needs to be registered
by your app's JavaScript.
If the page has never had a Service
Worker before, or the Service Worker has
been updated, the browser gets the new
service worker and installs it.
Once it's been installed,
it's then activated.
The Service Worker will then control
all the pages under the scope,
with one exception.
The page that is registered for
the Service Worker for
the first time, won't be controlled
until it's loaded again.
Once the Service Worker is in control,
it will handle fetch,
message, and push events that occur
whenever a network request or
message is sent from your page.
Note that a browser can terminate
a Service Worker to save memory.
But it will be restarted as needed.
If you want to dive deeper into Service
Workers, check out Jake's course.